all right we have new details about the
troubled history of the shooter who
killed nine people in Dayton Ohio
including his own sister the Dayton
Daily News reports former friends of the
gunman say he once talked about shooting
up a bar popular with students at the
University of Dayton in high school
classmates say he had both a hit list
and a rape list Dean Reynolds is in
Dayton Dean what's the latest on the
investigation
good morning police say they found at
least 41 shell casings here at the crime
scene from the gunman's legally obtained
and personally modified assault-style
rifle in addition they said he could
possibly have used some 250 additional
rounds of ammunition police stopped him
before he could use any of them and
enter a bar that was packed at the time
new cell phone video shows the chaos
inside the crowded Ned peppers bar in
Dayton's Oregon district when police
stormed in just seconds after officer
shot and killed Connor Betts who opened
fire on people outside he can be seen
face down here in the bars doorway
police with weapons still pointed at him
still amid the confusion and carnage
humanity to people in the middle of the
bar embracing hearing a weapon fired
like that in succession like that and
you don't know where it's coming from
like literally running for your life
Caitlin mujhey was in the Oregon
district when the shooting began on
Monday she went back to the scene to pay
respects to those who lost their lives I
just think that this is really sad
things aren't getting done to fix it the
gunman killed nine people in less than
30 seconds including his sister 22
year-old Megan bets it seems to justify
believability he would shoot his own
sister it's also hard to believe that he
didn't recognize that was his sister I
know he got off on making people afraid
Audrey Williams is a former high school
classmate of the shooter
she told Inside Edition he was a bully
and she'd heard he threatened to kill
one of his ex-girlfriend's he did make
threats often like just on a dime it was
like it didn't faze him like he didn't
have empathy towards what killing
somebody meant and today Ohio Governor
Mike DeWine proposed so-called
red flag legislation that allows law
enforcement or family members to remove
guns from someone who presents a danger
to himself or to others Dean thank you